hey guys we're the creators of ASAP
science and want to send a quick thank
you to all of you who have supported us
through these years by sharing and
watching our videos and especially
asking us all of your burning questions
our goal has been to reach as many
people as possible around the world and
make them realize that all their
experience is essentially everything
they do anything that they love it
really all has to do with science in
order to do that we've tried to make
science relatable accessible and most of
all fun but now we need your help we
decided early on that we're never gonna
ask our fans for money not that we have
an issue with those who do it was just a
personal decision but a lot of people
always ask us how they can support the
show and that's part of the reason why
we created this ASAP science book from
the science of selfies to the
five-second rule - why be square the
book is full of answers to questions
that you guys have asked us over the
years and science that we love and think
is really cool we're super super proud
of it and really think you're gonna like
it
if you've ever wanted to help us out
with our daily grind of researching and
producing videos or growing this channel
or even our second Channel ASAP thought
or if you just have a vested interest in
the mission of ASAP science which is to
make science and education more
accessible around the world then we'd be
so grateful if you did that by getting
the ASAP science book the book is not
only a chance for us to create new
science but it's actually a way for us
to reach a new audience give something
back to you for your support and also
help to show financially this will help
us grow our team make more videos and
most importantly help spread the ASAP
science mission further as it stands the
book is only available in certain
regions right now but if it does well in
our part of the world then hopefully
there'll be a greater possibility to get
it distributed all across the globe so
whether you want it for yourself what
you should or you want it for a friend
or you want to show it off in the toilet
it's a great book to put beside your
toilet there's a lots of stuff in there
about what goes on while you're in the
toilet that you can read into something
just know that every single pre-order
will help us reach this goal you can
head to ASAP science comm slash book to
support our show and get your copy now
we love you all we are so thankful for
all of your continued support and we are
so excited about the future and what it
holds for us and the expansion of all of
our brains continue to ask your burning
questions and we look forward to more
science and discovery together